When we moved out of the RV and into our house,
there was one thing that was on my must buy list
and it was fridge storage containers.
Because my kids go through fruit like it is their full time job,
and I like to keep it cut and washed
and ready for them to go at any time.
And this is a lifesaver. This is a five piece set,
five different sizes.
I really like this because it has the internal colander
that you can wash and dry your fruit
and then stick it right in there.
Keeps it off the ground so it doesn't get moldy.
And it has a lid so it's super easy.
They are air tight dishwasher and microwave safe.
But look at that. My kids can carry it around outside if they want to.
To have a picnic outside. It is so good.